me lo fai noleggiare questo bellissimo
scooter over bike che è un over by salve
io so guidare più o meno parcheggio
perfetto volo e si è fatto posso farvi
una domanda che mi sorge proprio
spontanea in questo caso ecco la
possibile che sto gioco uscito più di
due anni fa credo ma nonostante questo
gli sviluppatori continuano a creare
contenuti aggiuntivi
e pazzesco e la tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono felice ed
oggi siamo tornati sul gol simulator
incredibile perché dalla vita che non lo
faccio ma continuano uscire cose nuove è
uscito ragazzi miei ways of space nello
spazio non chiedetemi come né perché
però ho capito se tipo una parodia di
star wars solo che è uscito recentemente
sta aggiornamento e non ho capito per
cosa ne per come bello
scommetto che erano a capra guidare
quella roba lì non fa assolutamente una
piega giorno bene adesso che sei qua
come pensi di aiutarci a raggiungere il
nostro traguardo devo scegliere tra beh
beh facciamo bene ok grade news
ma come mi sono prima mente schiantato
guaranà vice che culo e dato non si sa
da dove sono arrivati da qua
certo perché quella roba lì è passato
ovviamente da sto buco microscopico
qualcuno mi apro la porta ed ho preso
dei soldi donne ha riparato la porta a
tanto ragazzi avete nottata la mia tuta
stratosferica quanto è [ __ ]
ma sono finte scale ma [ __ ] quindi
ragazzi il mio obiettivo è quello di
raccogliere soldi ho ucciso sto tizio mi
dispiace fra traggono è contento di
morire ascolta zio non era mente il
giorno anche a lei cosa devo fare i
profani stessa qui io devo dire devo
passare da un livello all'altro buttando
giù le persone che ho capito è compaiono
qua nel mezzo ma dai che figata barca
mia ecco qua ci sono soldi
se a me perché se io raccolgo soldi alal
si popola al posto ovviamente prossimo
obiettivo colonizzare il pianeta che al
traguardo maggiore un milione di dollari
quando cazzo di raggiungo la zia vi dà
dei soldi se te lo chiedo così giunti
grazie mille
me li ha dati non chiedetemi perché c'è
latifah che si sta lamentando però a dei
soldi che gli girano attorno quindi se
io la picchio tipo così è svenuta azie
ma niente mica si vede che c'è fascino
odio ha cambiato gestore perché l'altra
è morta mi servirebbero soldi anche
latte grazie mille porca [ __ ] dove è
finita non ma ci crede che ho fatto
canestro didastro punto qua come mi che
ho fatto
insomma adesso fa lei era diventata
dipendente va bene dal veto di applausi
frate potresti andare gentilmente giù
molto gentile o dio sia appeso la
campagna elettorale funziona di più così
e credimi ho creato una colonia
semplicemente prendendo a testate le
persone salve tale signora vuole un
hamburger
mi serviva no no no no va bene ok adesso
e va beh variamente sono uscito nello
sport ma c'è la gravità ma scusate come
possibile a non c'è la gravità cioè la
gravità e e tipo a minchia ai ragazzi
non importa lezioni di fisica by fa vj
nello spazio c'è gravità anche se poca
buongiorno o dio me lo fai noleggiare
questo bellissimo scooter over bike
okay un over my salve non credo che sia
contento di vedermi valvo nuovo no al si
tolga tocca a me mi dovrei noleggiare un
over bike buongiorno mi su poi li metto
al posto il tavolo promesso mi fanno
leggere una bici una cosa le ho legato
alla sedia ma lei faccia finta che ci
sia ancora bravo sia seduto mi
servirebbe una moto posso prendere ma
dopo lo stavo prendendo il volo grazie
di qualcuno che da una quest buongiorno
cosa fai sbocci ma no ma cos'è lo so io
dove è in quella in mezzo che si
continuano a discute non sono ma anche
accorti pazzie ve di truffa qualcun
altro grazie
ora che esce un tasto l'osso quando
vedete un tasto così in un videogioco
quanti temi come fate a non schiacciarlo
non è possibile cioè la prima cosa che
non sa neanche cosa faccia prova be
[Musica]
attiva
oddio a caso ma perché è stata fatto sto
povero cristiano l'aveva vuole ma per
che cosa
e va bene mi ha stordito senza motivo si
stupiscono da soli ma corre per quale
motivo che ha fatto sbloccato qualcosa
ten tirando testate i robot
ho chiamato lo ho sbloccato l'over mai
ce l'ho fatta la gara posso allora g to
some e va bene quanto sono figo levatevi
da cazzo io so guidare più o meno il
prossimo traguardo è un personal
spacecraft spiegatevi che cosa c'era
dentro che figo al museo il permesso
grazie ho sbloccato al posto quindi
posso entrare grazie mille salve
lo so che sei una cagna zia e vuole
dimostrarlo però questo è fatto apposta
per me devo entrare io grazie detto che
bello fammi vedere quant'è bello questo
quadro non me lo fa vedere maledizione
master blaster veri safe in piena
sicurezza
ragazzi se sapete che si attivò ste cose
quella lì si carbonizza vero non so come
pro ci devo provare fermi tutti i temi
che si possono accendere vi prego
potremmo via da ridere bottoni
importante perchè rosso è vero io lo
sapevo anch'io questa tecnica quanto lo
adora quanto posso adorare questo gioco
vi prego è troppo bello ma ragazzi direi
che ho fatto tutto il possibile nel
museo a parte tipo rubare i soldi asso
tizio il mercatino dell'usato nello
spazio posso comprare questo cappello
bellissimo no vabbè esploso il tizio
senso motiva bene di testa di testa va
bene quasi prova a fare una roba legano
so se mi riesce però ci provo
l'amato ce l'ho fatta giorno potresti
darmi dei soldi che dovevo bisogno ma no
ma poverino si scusa ti giuro che non
volevo già che ci siamo ti picchio noi
ne posso fare figure di merda
noi stiamo entrando aiuto il parcheggio
perfetto se solo si è fatto piace zio
giuro che non volevo si è fatto male se
diamanti minecraft che cazzo ne
servirebbe capire perché ho appena
buttato giù luke skywalker
ma voi la sta merda ma che ne so io ma
di te l'ho mai vada che non le spiegano
le cose che già sono una capra ci siamo
ragazzi dovrei riuscire a sbloccare
qualcosa adesso lo space kraft è va bene
quanto figo personal quindi io posso
andare nello spazio adesso non è fatto e
come l'uso devo andare qua sopra lega
che ciò la mia navicella che mi aspetta
scusatemi ma quanto figlio space poli
fame sia come come funziona bene devo
muovere le zampe ma non è vero
sì va bene ma neanche so guidare da
fermo ma non potete farmi questo già
allora come sid e decollo decollo
decollo clicca questo tasto rosso che
sembra quello giusto allora fatemi capi
thrive responsi palo agli proviamoci
perché non ho capito niente allora primo
tasto da premere perde col decollo oh sì
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ha fatta
sono forte sorrida re l'astronave dio
quanto casinò storto io sortito
stortissimo ok sono nello spazio non
posso schiantarmi questa ecco non
possiamo fare così anche le strade che
se prendo la patente potrebbe essere un
pericolo ragazzi ho capito allora devo
premere il tasto culo a caso il tasto
cooper schiacciare i tasti e con una
zampa oriento e con l'altra guido bene
come cazzo fatta cadere ma porca [ __ ]
ma non è vero ma dai mi sono
dematerializzate vabbè ma ha fatto
ripartire il quale salva ragazzi non
erano tranquilli continuate a depilare
le persone come state facendo tanto sono
belli convinti di essere depilati questi
servirebbe solo sapere se c'è un bagno
non è un attrezzo giusto per depilare
quello è dimitri ma è un robot testata
al cuscino ma che cucina un uomo quello
ma non è vero ma non è un cuscino tate
creando ah ho capito degli esemplari di
cuscini a forma di uomo scusate non
avevo capito eh la madonna questo
cuscino si muove pure lui e l'amato non
è vero non ci credo ci mancavano le
spade lhasa mi sembrava che non fosse
abbastanza epico suo gioco ragazzine che
posso concludere che questo primo
episodio di coop simulator
non so con quanta fantasia riescano a
continuare a far uscire contenuti visto
gioco il creato
questa roba però li fanno e quello che
mi sorprende fantastico quindi ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio spero che video
vi sia piaciuto e costo ita 62 vabbè
vabbè lasciate un commento mi piace al
capace di facebook ecco mio totale
descrizione prestiti sia ci vediamo al
prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]